shane is with us in new york city with a
similar question hey shane how are you
hey how you guys doing today great good
how can we help
all right
you're going to speak directly into your
phone it's muffled oh sorry about that
is it better now yes sir thank you
all right so last year i was going to
a university which my parents took out a
loan for about
it was a period plus month i took it out
for about
22 000 and um
i made a decision to transfer schools to
a
uh cheaper school and i was making the
payments myself
to that school because i did not want to
go into debt
uh unfortunately um my job had a little
issue
and i'm out of the job for about two
months now but i'm coming back next
month
so in order to cover the rest of the
year i ended up taking out a loan to
cover the rest of the school year for
fifty five hundred
um that's that was the one i took out
and um the thing is though is that
personally speaking i would not even go
to school i have very traditional
parents who say i must go to school as
long as i live under their household
that type of rule and um only because
i'm not sure what i really want to do
yet in life so
i don't see the point of spending money
to do something i don't even know what i
want to do yet
what are you studying um finance
and you're in your second year uh yes
okay and now you're at a less expensive
school in the first year
yes okay and you're how old i'm 19.
okay and you're saying that you don't
know if you want to do this
if you want to be in the finance world
when you graduate
yes because my heart has been set out
for
real estate for the past three years
okay but my parents
uh again under their household they want
me to do
something that they can go to a school
and having that they think we'll pay a
lot
yeah and um so and i know
for a fact you don't really need a
degree to become a real estate agent
like um they want me to get a finance
degree or
computer degree one of the two so
respectfully saying i do not believe it
is
um right for the parent to tell their
son or daughter their child
what to do with their life um
i don't see there's a problem with your
parents saying hey if you look
live up underneath this house you have
to abide by these rules that's
respectful that's their house
but i think right now you have to make a
decision for yourself
what do you want to do at the age that
you're at um
if you're saying hey i want to be in
real estate
um i've never done real estate dave can
speak into that but i know
it's a wow before you generate any
income i do believe some form of
education is important
uh for whatever you're going to do but i
think
right now especially taking out money no
you need to stop that process
but you do need to be working if you're
going to quit college but i think most
importantly man
you need to spend some time and identify
what it is that you really want to do
not just real estate
but even long term if that is real
estate for the next 20 30 years
okay cool but i think you need to go out
there and experience life a little bit
maybe get you a solid job that can
provide that you can move into your own
apartment maybe some roommates spend a
year to just dip and dab out there and
different things
once you identify what that is then what
our career
expert here ken coleman says then figure
out what does it take to get to that
uh but right now i i i would say
um pause because if you're saying you're
going to school and you're borrowing
money you're paying for something
that you really don't even really want
to do pause
but then when you pause you got to have
a game plan because now your parents
won't allow you to stay there
yeah for sure um how would you say you
are oh
i'm 19. okay well here's something to
consider
how many 35 45 and 55 year olds buy a
house from a 19 year old real estate
agent
that's going to be a hard road yeah it
can be done
i actually did it but it was a hard road
i mean i had my magnum pi mustache and
my disco suit on and i'm out there
trying to sell houses at 18 years old
19 years old i sold a few but it's just
because i worked my
butt off and and i was bold and
everything else but
it's a very difficult
trek to start residential real estate at
19 years old it can be done
i'm not saying it's impossible but i do
want you to know that that's
a little different than you rolling in
there at 29.
um in terms of credibility and who
you're dealing with and and how you get
started and all that so
what i would think is that maybe we uh
uh
address a couple of other things and
let's take a step back
i'm not disagreeing with anthony i'm
adding to it
uh number one we're both saying no more
debt yeah
okay for school that's silly but this
school that you're in now is affordable
you just got to get six jobs and be able
to pay your way through
that's what it amounts to and so that's
just
what's necessary the um
uh uh uh you know and so you're gonna
pay your way through now that's step one
and step two is do you want to continue
to study finance
uh i got a degree in finance with a
specialization in real estate that was
what my degree was in
and that's how i end up you know someday
a thousand years later sitting here
but uh uh and it did it served me well
the academic
uh you know the underpinning of learning
statistics learning marketing
learning accounting the things you learn
to do finance are
those are good classes that are very
usable
in almost any business situation and so
whether you're the owner of a small
business whether you're in real estate
uh whether you own a company that does x
y or z or whether you
um go to work for somebody that in
almost any industry they're going to
need people that know those things
so i don't mind you continuing with the
finance degree as long as you pay cash
for it
or switching degree fields and pay cash
and stay at home and but you're going to
get six jobs to do that
you're going to rethink this right now
you just feel like you're being pushed
around by everybody involved
and you're just being you know this is
feels random and you need to get the
randomness out of it absolutely